the Joe Rogan experience we did this
fight companion podcast on Saturday
night Saturday during the day if you
fight the fights were from New Zealand
the UFC fights before the tides of fury
but yeah Deontay Wilder fight and we
were talking about it and my friend
Eddie was like how come they don't do
something like this on TV I'm like they
couldn't there's no way we're drinking
we have whiskey we're smoking weed we're
talking crazy [ __ ] you know Brendan
Schaub every girl on the lit this
bitch's ass and this net
everyone's talking crazy it's they're
talking like guys normally talk we're
sitting around but we're doing it over
the Internet yeah but it gets millions
of views so it's one of those things
were like if a network had a show like
that they'd be like this is a hit it's a
giant hit for a sports show that's why
for a sports show to get way more views
than the actual show it's watching so
it's a fight companion we're watching
the fights and we're talking about the
fights but that gets more than twice as
many views as the actual fights itself
which is kind of crazy that's very great
but the only way that happens is if no
executive none of those half in half out
people we're talking about before that
it really could work at the Discovery
Channel or the History Channel they're
trying to cute and things up trying to
take the edge off look guys we're gonna
cut that segment when you're talking
about those girls asses it's just kind
of disrespectful and you know I've got
kids of my own and I've got daughters
like get the [ __ ] out of here like you
know if we had a producer in here
they're like some some networks flows in
right there oh my god giving us notes at
the end of every show yeah I wouldn't do
it yeah when I worked going on
late-night talk shows the hoenn aired of
a freedom of speech was in the air and
that's whenever we would write something
it all had to be legally approved by
that's the first time I saw that oh
anybody like you guys can't say you know
all right man sorry
you know we'd figured out you know yeah
in ways and then and then out you'd go
out in the world people like freedom of
speech oh man this [ __ ] is all legally
approved man like what you're seeing in
this space is it's not like you said
like but but when you guys could just
say whatever you want is to narrow it
down those few voices as possible to
have control like this does you
you and me and and Jamie's hanging out
this is a three-man crew that reaches
millions and millions of people that's
insane
like that's insane that's never happened
before but that's the only reason why it
works yeah because you don't have any
like my sensibilities are all [ __ ] up
they're not normal like what I think is
okay but in terms of drugs and violence
and all the different things that I
enjoy yes I mean I'm a hunter I bibo
hunt animals you know yeah that's what I
eat I ever smoked pot all the time you
know I'm always swearing like I don't
believe in any of these things I I you
know I just think that when you're when
you're putting together a show there's
no way you would ever let a person like
me be responsible for the the the job of
promoting something to push out like
being the captain of a show well you got
all these executives and their jobs are
on the line and you're gonna have some
loose cannon like me who's a wild
stand-up comic like everything I've done
has been wildly OH from the beginning
from fighting to getting the stand up
from all it's wild it's wild stuff you
know that's what I like I like when it's
chaos that's what I enjoy yeah but
there's no way you could ever have a
network approved something like this
there's no way the language saying [ __ ]
saying whatever the [ __ ] you want to say
talking about things in an honest way
talking about what's [ __ ] about life
about politics about the the state of
the way human beings communicate with
each other yeah you gotta boil it down
in just a couple of people when you boil
it down especially guys like you and me
who are comics yeah who could talk real
about stuff who aren't scared of saying
their flaws aren't scared of saying
where they [ __ ] up and how you know
it's those some of my favorite
conversations and when you talk about
this [ __ ] you [ __ ] up when you were
young and dumb it's fun people hide from
that stuff yeah they don't like it they
don't like to feel like they're
inadequate or or their ways they can
feel like they were always good like
that's all nonsense yeah this kind of
thing were you doing a podcast this is I
think this is the future of all those
talk shows those talk shows are
dwindling
they are like they're like flowers in
the desert man they're not getting
enough water
no one watching if you look at the
numbers like Conan's show it's horrible
and you know he's a legend yeah and all
these guys are legends but there's no
one's watching that [ __ ] anymore
because you could watch this or any
other podcasters something like 900,000
of them oh wow and you could watch them
or listening to them anytime you want
yeah you could stop it when you have to
take a [ __ ] you can come back you know
you don't have to wait for it to come on
you know none of that nonsense yeah you
listen in your car you could watch it in
on your computer oh I think this is and
people are being real the this is a
different world now with the Internet
there's too much real information for
you to get spoon-fed nonsense on
television you know let those like when
I watch those CBS shows like those crime
shows I'm like oh people are watching
this right old people and people that
like have chemicals at work and they
come home drunk you know I mean like
there's something about it something in
the air we just want to sit and have
something mindless spoon-fed to them
exist oh that's those Network shows
that's what keeps those things alive
yeah those things are so watered down so
nonsense is it not real life
[Applause]